this is evan langer reading for reviewer
kevin kenizevic
mario's 25th anniversary was marked with
a wii re-release of super mario
all-stars of all things
hardly the most auspicious way to
commemorate such a remarkable milestone
this year however nintendo is giving
mario a more fitting anniversary tribute
headlining the festivities with super
mario 3d all-stars
a switch compilation featuring a trio of
the plumber's most influential
adventures
n64 super mario 64 gamecube super mario
sunshine
and wii super mario galaxy the games
that are included here are some of
mario's most memorable and they've all
been given an hd sheen
mario 64 runs in 720p whether you're
playing on the television or in handheld
mode
while sunshine and galaxy both run in
1080p docked and 720p
handheld thanks to the increased
resolution the games all look more
vibrant
and colorful than ever which helps mask
their otherwise aging visuals
galaxy in particular has benefited
greatly from the hd touch-up and is
often stunning
the ui elements in each game look much
crisper as well and the in-game text has
been updated to reflect the tweaked
controls
in mario 64's case the fuzzy font has
been smoothed over
making it much easier to read beyond
those nips and tucks however
3d all-stars presents the three classics
in their original unvarnished forms
outside of modified controls to better
suit the switch hardware nintendo has
not altered the content of these games
so they arrive on switch with all their
original highlights and blemishes intact
as such the appeal of this collection
hinges entirely on the strength of the
games themselves
and they all have weathered the test of
time with varying degrees of grace
[Music]
as the oldest game in the compilation
mario 64 has aged the most noticeably
something that is immediately apparent
in the controls
while mario himself still feels as spry
and acrobatic as ever he doesn't quite
feel as sharp to maneuver as he once did
his turn radius is a bit unwieldy and
his walk a little too jittery which
often makes it difficult to guide him
across narrow pathways
or line him up to read signposts or
speak to other characters
the biggest sticking point however is
the camera system pioneering as it was
in 1996 the camera is often an
impediment restrictive at the best of
times and combative at the worst
you can only shift the camera angle
around in increments but even then it
has a tendency to drift back behind
mario making it difficult to frame jumps
and other actions that require tight
rope precision
this can get particularly frustrating in
some of the game's later stages where
death defying leaps become the norm and
you'll need to rely on the camera to
gauge your trajectory
given the game's age however these flaws
are to be expected and they're largely
overshadowed by its many endearing
strengths
while the ideas here would be
reinterpreted and refined by later games
in the series
mario 64's sense of adventurousness
remains undiminished
princess peach's castle the game's
labyrinth and hub is loaded with secrets
to uncover and it remains a joy to
explore
rewarding curiosity with hidden stars
and secret stages
the game is particularly clever in the
way it builds expectations only to later
subvert them you'll spend your first
handful of hours learning that levels
are accessed via paintings
only for the game to disguise the
entrance to one later stage as a
nondescript wall
these little moments of discovery are
plentiful and always feel rewarding to
stumble upon
the game's novelty on the whole may have
been somewhat diminished by the passage
of time
but is still able to surprise and
delight often
super mario sunshine is commonly
regarded as something of an odd duck
among the mario series a game with as
many detractors as
advocates and it's much easier to see
why when it's juxtaposed with two of
mario's most acclaimed outings much of
it boils down to the clumsily named
flash liquidizer ultra dowsing device or
flood
a water spewing contraption that mario
wears on his back throughout most of the
adventure
while the plumber is still able to leap
and slide around levels with acrobatic
abandon
flutt is his primary means of
interacting with the world around him in
sunshine
you'll use it to battle bosses hit far
off panels and clean up goop while
additional nozzles give flood the
ability to launch mario into the air
like a rocket or zip around at high
speeds
in the same way that mario 64 showcased
the n64's analog stick
flood was a showpiece for the gamecube
controller's analog shoulder buttons
pressing down on the right trigger
lightly would let mario spray water
while moving while holding the trigger
down fully stopped him in his tracks
allowing you to aim more precisely
since the switch controller lacks analog
triggers these actions have been divided
up between the zr and
r buttons it's a suitable workaround and
you also have no choice but to adapt to
these changes since 3d all-stars
inexplicably doesn't support the
gamecube controller with the original
controls
the heavy reliance on flood however
places sunshine in stark contrast to
other mario games
largely because you never feel is
completely in control of the action
this is especially true in stages that
task you to steer a boat the problem is
that it's next to impossible to maneuver
the vehicle with any degree of finesse
this way so you'll be clumsily ramming
it into walls as you try to steer around
obstacles situations like this are
prevalent in sunshine and illustrate how
uneven it feels compared to other mario
games
it's never as inventive or adventurous
as 64 galaxy
nor is it as meticulously crafted its
challenges are not as finely tuned and
many of the objectives it throws at you
feel like busy work to extend your
playtime
even the presentation is a mess sunshine
is famous for being the first mario game
to feature fully voiced cutscenes if you
don't count peach's brief snippets of
dialogue in mario 64.
this will be laudable where not for the
fact that the cutscenes and voice work
are truly terrible
so much so that no other mario game
would use fully voiced dialogue again
after it
go straight that way you can't miss the
mess now
your first job is to get rid of all that
ugliness
and remember we'll be watching you pal
we'll know if you start blacking off
that's not to say sunshine is completely
devoid of any merits however
even with all these faults there are
plenty of aspects to like about sunshine
particularly its setting isle delfino
a hawaii by way of the mushroom kingdom
tropical island spanning seven levels
and numerous hidden one-off challenges
in keeping with the tropical theme all
of the areas you visit are designed to
resemble island locales from an
amusement park to a port harbor spider
webbed with catwalks
these levels are all charmingly realized
and feel like genuine areas rather than
play pens designed around mario's
abilities
this gives sunshine the strongest sense
of place of any 3d mario game and it's
fun to simply run about the levels and
soak in the scenery
mario's first wii adventure rounds out
the collection and it holds up as the
best of the bunch
as fresh and exciting to play now as it
was when it first launched in 2007.
much of that has to do with the game's
pacing contrasted with the meandering
and uneven challenges in sunshine galaxy
is sharply focused
pairing back the sandbox style levels of
previous 3d mario games for a more
linear series of challenges
although the stages don't offer as much
room for exploration the variety of
ideas within each is delightful
galaxy never stays in one place for very
long throwing a variety of micro
objectives at you and root to the power
star waiting at the end of every stage
the entire adventure unspools at a rapid
clip as well new galaxies open up after
every few stars you collect
and many of the levels are one-off
challenges designed around a specific
gameplay idea making them constantly
surprising
not all these ideas are winners those
that are designed around controller
gimmicks such as the motion controls
manta surfing challenges
aren't as fun or inspired as the other
stages but the game never lingers on one
idea for long whisking you off to the
next challenge before you grow
frustrated
given that it was originally designed
around motion controls mario galaxy has
received the most substantial control
tweaks in its move to switch
you can still play the game wii style
with one joy con in each hand and this
setup still feels like the most natural
way to experience the adventure as it
most easily lets you maneuver mario
around and use the star cursor
simultaneously
because the switch lacks a sensor bar
however you'll need to manually recenter
the reticle often but this is done
easily enough
simply by pressing the r button there
are other controller options beyond the
traditional setup but all of them
utilize motion in some capacity and
don't feel quite as natural as using two
joy-cons
taken all together mario 3d all-stars is
a worthwhile collection featuring the
best versions of mario 64
sunshine and galaxy to appear on a
nintendo system although the individual
games have been sparingly touched up and
there's little in the way of ancillary
material to pour over
the titles themselves hold up well and
are delight to revisit despite their age
the games are still rife with inventive
ideas and surprises which more than make
up for the collection's presentational
[Music]
shortcomings
you